so what are some of the cons
okay well let's go back and forth you do
one and i'll do one okay that's great
that's great
so here's the con here's a huge con
think about uh this is my my general
thing i'm going to start with people are
the product of their environment right
we are all the products of our
environment that's why you know you're
the people that you deal with
you're the five people you spend the
most time with you probably heard that
saying right
and women are no different right and
professional women are no different
they are in an environment that is hyper
competitive that is hyper aggressive
that has
hyper we'll call it masculine energy but
you know it's there
and they're having to fight and argue
all day now
a lot of people in those sort of jobs
you know even doctors when you're
yelling when you're commanding when
you're you know bossing people around
cops same issue too when they come home
here's the problem
they don't know how to turn it off
they've never been taught
or even have the skills to turn that off
when they come home they're still
talking before
maybe but i love to bring it up and i
feel like we've talked about i don't
know i feel like maybe i've talked to
somebody else about this
maybe it was behind the scenes but i i i
say over and over again
they do not know how to turn that
off yeah i would i would completely
agree with that that's one of the
downsides that that that hyper
competitiveness all day long
like you know i say say this to guys all
the time like
you don't want to be out chasing
excellence all day long putting a dental
universe and coming home to some hyper
competitive
boss girl you know bag that's at
you
all night because something's not gone
her way
um you're gonna listen to a lot of
office stuff
and there's nicknames for everybody and
the weirdest nicknames i've ever heard
like ghetto
you know it's like really that's you
know that's what you call people in a
law firm that you don't like
you know uh like oh like
diaper mom uh the part-time people
like like there's names for everything
right so um i mean like yeah you're
gonna deal with that on a personal level
after the work hours work will come home
and you're going to be listening to
a lot of that professional person in
your face
in the evening i agree with andrew i
think they have a very very hard time
turning that off and
guys generally speaking that are on a
purpose that are making
some serious bank they don't want
disagreeable women they want somebody
that that's that's pleasant
they want to come home to somebody
that's pleasant that's you know made a
nice meal or
you know i don't care wants to massage
your back maybe
i can't believe he said that misogynist
god forbid you do anything nice for a
man
but you get the idea right okay so
that's so that's certainly one of the
other cons
um what else we got on the con scale
well that's your
now it's your turn you got it you got to
go long hours i'll tell you
i'll tell you something there was i i
had no idea what was involved with being
a lawyer until you date a lawyer like my
phone would ring
at 11 30 12 30 at night
and i'd be like hey what are you calling
me for i'm just on my dinner
you're having dinner break at like 12 at
midnight yeah yeah i got this big deal
that i got to close and i'm not going to
finish it until like 4am
you're going to be there until 4am are
you serious yeah and i got to take a
taxi home after taking the subway home
and
all the trains and everything and take a
shower stick for an hour and go back and
do it all over again
are you like are you crazy like
this is what you do
this is what some professionals have to
do
uh there's some doc like usually the
junior doctors are working on
shifts so they get the crappier shifts
because the younger ones so they get the
crappier times
junior lawyers the same thing they're
the ones there all night
the partners go home they go home to
their families you know
they're cool but it's the junior lawyers
that you're dating that are
28 29 30 35 maybe or so that are working
crazy hours and um sometimes
you'll you'll be like all right let's
get together friday night
and you're sitting down maybe you're
netflix and chill and she's
out cold by 7 30. like
sleeping asleep and you're like what am
i gonna do with this tonight
yeah yeah and i'll i'll i'll double down
on that in two ways because i
have experience with this is that you
know and you know with lawyers obviously
look as a lawyer
i know there were days weeks where i
worked 70 80 hours a week no joke
absolutely yeah you have to you're the
bottom of the barrel and the work never
stops
as soon as you finish there's more
assignments to be given you but i'll use
it in a doctor context because i was
dealing with a doctor and you'd think it
was it was cool because like i mentioned
in the pros
they use their time efficiently you know
she'd text me and say hey
come over and i knew what that meant we
all know what that means when she says
come over directly to my place we're not
going to dinner we're not doing anything
else
and i think some guys are like oh my god
that's awesome she's telling you to just
come over
here's the problem she was telling me to
do it at 1 pm
sorry like 2 p.m the middle of the
afternoon in the middle of the morning
because she was on weird hours and she
would only have
an hour or two break or some middle a
little bit of time and i've got to
squeeze into her schedule
to try to come and you know do my duty
but when
i'm ready to go when i'm saying hey it's
the end of the work week i need to blow
off some steam here baby she's
she's working she's locked up i can't
see her for days and what i've got to
wait and sit on my hands
while i'm doing that no way no way and
as a
you know guy who's taking control of his
circumstances i'm not going to let her
dictate my schedule in the when i want
things
right yeah um
one of the other downsides too is with
professional women is because of the
stress and the workload is they do age
prematurely
um there's this concept of the wall in
the space that we talk about
and you know they often say that you
know women hit the wall around 22 23
after that they're on the sexual
marketplace decline and
you know their attractiveness starts to
go down a lot of people like to debate
this
fine you guys argue in the corner over
there this is our take on it
um so working the long hours crappy diet
a lot of
ordered food um less time to work out
they're not seeing the kids right
outsourcing the kids because they're
outsourcing the kids yeah you know if
they've got kids if you're dating a
divorced chick that's a professional
she's got kids they're gonna be with
their mom
the nanny crazy you know stuff like that
but um you know the smart guys that
watch me they're not messing with single
moms now anymore
um yeah they're like you know the
equivalent 35 year old
lawyer is probably not going to be as
attractive as the equivalent 35 year old
chick that doesn't have those kind of
working hours and stress you know
teachers for example have a lot you know
lower hours and they get paid
almost as well here it's about 100 grand
is what they make
yeah and you can work other jobs i mean
like i said i i've had really good
experiences with for example uh dating
nurses right
they have much different hours they seem
to be and you know once much more
amenable
than when i'm looking to professionals
right so the nurse versus the doctor the
paralegal versus the lawyer
there's a huge huge huge difference um
one thing let me bring up the next one
is um they really you have to understand
professionals have internalized
feminism and every single belief that
you believe about this the myth of the
strong independent woman that can have
it all they
of any class of women they are kind of
like held up as the icons so
because they're held up put on a
pedestal people will point to them
saying look at her she has it all
they internalize that more than perhaps
any
other class of uh women yeah they're
like um
it's almost like a chameleon right
because they internalize feminist
indoctrination and beliefs but they
don't look the part
right you know for the most part you
know especially down in miami you're
going to find more of the enhanced
ladies
but um yeah so you're not going to
like it's going to be confusing because
you're going to see what looks like a
feminine beauty but embodies
you know typical toxic feminist
narratives a lot of the times too so
that's
yeah that's an important point too i've
had i've had literally i've been on uh
actually it's crazy during the pandemic
i i did this just because sometimes i
would pull dates just uh you know
for dating practice even though i know
this one is going to be a strikeout
but this is the beginning of the
pandemic and she didn't want to meet up
she just wanted to do a skype date so i
said screw it
i'll grab a you know grab a scotch here
and i'll like you know have fun with
this you know
um and you know this lady got
on with me you know girl she's actually
younger than me but you know she's a
fellow attorney and was just ramping on
the patriarchy and how men are horrible
and men's standards
and i'm like and i just straight up told
her i said i said do you think this is
the way you should behave for a first
date i mean i was red pill at this point
so at this point i'm just having fun
you know i said what guy do you think
would think you're pleasant and nice to
be around or want to be around you at
all what human would want to be around
you
if all you do on the first date is
complain about men but that's
that's where their heads are at
especially the ones that you know as
you're saying if you've adopted the
kind of red pro framework you know when
you're looking at women getting older
wanting to have kids and getting
frustrated that they're not there
that they don't have at all they're just
going to act more and more and more
aggressive
you